[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to ubisoft
forward
i'm neela and i'm yusuf we're so
thrilled to be back hosting ubisoft
forward
over the next hour we'll be your guides
to all the latest news and exciting
announcements coming from ubisoft
we've got so much in store for you today
including deeper looks at far cry 6
writer's republic and rainbow six plus a
few other surprises you'll find out
about soon enough
neelum i'm excited we're filming this
together we got this gorgeous set
e3 is back but i know why y'all are here
you want to see games so let's get right
into it the rainbow six operators are
facing off against an evolving and
deadly threat
you'll no doubt have noticed that the
alien parasite has spread to new areas
it's time to suit up and step into the
containment zone here's a deeper look
at rainbow six extraction
[Applause]
i used to feel so much peace
staring into the heavens until a piece
of it fell
and the nightmare began
we thought it could be contained
but it evolved so we
did too one of our own is m.i.a i need
an extraction team
now
if there's a way to stop them
you will find it
[Music]
but i know
you will find me first
okay i'll take out the nests
i have a signal let's go
we are already out of the nests incoming
stand back
clear let's move out
i found her
hey better hold on
coming through
an apex
[Music]
not so fast
hey you all throwing me a party
yeah do about you missed all the
fireworks
team it's ash we're not done yet vip
down
[Music]
now i know you must have a ton of
questions after seeing that trailer
and we have answers as well as a full
gameplay walkthrough coming up
so hang tight my name is richard i'm
your resident community developer coming
to you from north carolina
we're thrilled to be back to give you an
introduction to rainbow six extraction
with me today in montreal i have bruno
lalon our lead technical director
and alicia fortier game designer to help
walk us through
alicia what can we tell our players
about extraction
extraction is a one to three player
co-op experience
you might think you know what you're
getting into since there's gonna be some
of your favorite rainbow six operators
but it's gonna be completely different
because this time you're not
fighting against each other you're
coming together to face an unprecedented
evolving alien threat some of the
operators abilities
gadgets and tech should feel familiar to
siege players
but this time as you progress through
the game you'll unlock new ability
upgrades
and a whole new arsenal specifically
designed to take on this new threat
so the operators we just saw in that
trailer are very familiar
but what happened to hibana she got
captured
in extraction you're always putting it
all on the line if your teammate falls
during an incursion you're gonna go
missing in action
you can't play mia operators until
they're safely recovered
you and your squad are gonna have to
come back together to get back in there
and get them
out every time
you go in the containment zone you risk
losing all your progress
and upgrades so stay on your toes and
weigh
every move you make balancing that risk
and reward scenario is going to be tough
bruno can you tell us a little bit more
about the alien threat
what is it who are they and where do
they come from
what we know is the arkins or evil form
of the parasite that was first detected
few years ago
during the outbreak event in new mexico
but a lot have changed since
the parasite has spread to three new
regions emerging and several containment
zones
within new york san francisco and alaska
this is what we know so far within the
contentment zones
the alien ecostem is in a continual
evolution
as incubation-ness and their sprawling
tissue
spawn procedurally taking over the front
area of the map
and reaction to the player presents the
parasite is always spreading
always evolving but it didn't look too
happy about the operators disturbing
their new home
what are we facing off against well the
black goo like sprawl
is probably the first thing you will
take on it spreads to the map
once your presence is detected slowing
your progress
and helping the arcanes some of the
other traits you may have seen on the
trailer
are the long range spiker the explosive
creatures
the shape-shifting tormentors and the
epics
there's a lot more species of our kings
and mutations that have been observed
more to come on that very soon
thank you both so much for joining me
i'm really excited to dig into more of
the details
we still have crossplay to talk about
yes that's right
extraction will bring everyone together
regardless of the platform
and for our rainbow six siege community
we have exclusive unlocks for you
in both games okay you've been waiting
long enough
let's take an exclusive first look at
some gameplay footage
here is rainbow six extraction
welcome to rainbow six extraction the
new tactical co-op shooter game where
rainbow six operators are dropped into
alien territory
in today's walk through we're on a
mission to investigate anomalies
identified at the orpheus research
center in alaska
hq will provide additional instructions
we need new data on the parasites
underground network
it keeps evolving adapting plant auto
trackers on dormant nests
don't destroy them or will lose the
trackers
as a squad of three ella alibi and
sledge will use their operator abilities
to complete objectives
assist each other and obliterate
archaeans in their way spinning up
that's a grunt easy for a nest to
incubate and bring to life
not so easy to eliminate in large
numbers converge on location
nice and quiet the enemy reacts to
intrusions in their ecosystems
including operators eliminate my target
so stealth tactics are the way to go
visual on nest place auto trackers for
our react scientists
auto tracker activated
[Music]
the parasite generates sprawl a
substance that connects the whole
ecosystem
alert an archaean and a nearby nest
wakes up too
our kians move faster in sprawl but
operators get slowed down
take my guy out the squad can use their
react light to see bioluminescent
properties on archaeans and in the
environment
the contrast helps to better identify
targets
[Music]
nest mapping complete a scientist just
gave me the thumbs up good job
identifying our key invariants helps the
team determine the best approach to take
them out
[Music]
spotted a router it can immobilize
anyone in front of it
so sledge will swing around back
get out of there before the swarm
appears don't push your luck
go
that was close here the team can regroup
and resupply
airlock doors will open onto the next
subzone which will be tougher than the
first
we need tissue samples from those arches
and we need them gone
use your react blade
[Music]
oh
it's right there react blade do your
thing
one down we're not done yet
that's your target don't put it to death
just yet
get that sample we've located a spiker
it can fire armor-piercing projectiles
alibi deploys a prisma hologram
the squad can use react tech to go
further in incursions
the more intel they collect the more
tech they'll have at their disposal to
fight off this threat it's all about
teamwork to outsmart the enemy
barricade that spot reinforcing before
creating a chokepoint is a good idea to
increase the arc mine's efficiency
that's the way keep hunting that's the
react threat sensor smasher incoming
wow that did it take out the leader no
leader for the archies to follow
another objective completed the squad
can either x-fill at the extraction
point to bring home the latest intel
or move to the next airlock the third
subzone will be the most challenging yet
a true test of both tactical team
strategy and operator reflexes
some arcanes are responding to an elite
as if they're communicating
no way we'd let them mobilize against us
hunt them down until the elite comes out
of hiding
[Music]
huh
the elite will show up any second
enemy located
is
an operator is now m.i.a i don't know if
you can hear this but we're mounting a
rescue hang tight
heard it a rescue mission is underway
react still needs you
operators it's time to unite and stand
together against this emerging threat
squad up with friends in co-op
or step into the containment alone stay
tuned for more rainbow six extraction
intel coming very soon
if you think fighting aliens is tough
try learning guitar
well that was a segue ten years ago
rocksmith redefined music learning by
introducing the first console game that
taught
millions how to play guitar whether
you're already an expert or just
starting out
rocksmith has an approach that's for
everyone a fun and interactive way to
learn your favorite songs
and in the decades since its release
community this year let's turn it up to
11 and see what's next for rocksmith
[Music]
[Music]
a song for you a road in memory
[Music]
silence
in the afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
song for you
it's all for you
a song for you
i'm arthur von egel producer at ubisoft
san francisco
and rocksmith has truly been a dream
project for me
as a lifelong gamer and a touring
musician rocksmith is what i wish i had
when i started learning music and that's
why i'm thrilled to share
the next evolution of music learning
rocksmith
plus a new interactive music learning
subscription service
available this year learn how to play
guitar and bass
by playing along to master recordings of
your favorite songs
connect your instrument to your pc
console or mobile device
and get real-time feedback as you play
connecting with rocksmith plus will be
easier than ever
now that you can use your phone as a
microphone
download the app log in sync to
rocksmith plus
set it down and play along now acoustic
players
and electric players with amps can use
rocksmith plus
with no extra gear needed it's a game
changer
[Music]
and we're excited to reveal rocksmith
plus will have a
huge amount of songs at launch all songs
in the library will have chord charts
that will be perfect for rhythm players
who want to learn the foundation of a
song
to hum and strum along to we'll still
have the note for note
authentic arrangements for players that
want to play songs
exactly how the artists originally
played them and each week
we release a steady stream of new
authentic arrangements
to keep growing that portion of the
library we're also introducing
the rocksmith workshop a new tool that
lets users
create and add their own arrangements
for songs we've licensed
your subscription will give you access
to all those songs
more content than ever before including
genres beyond rock
we'll have pop hip hop country latin r
b all sorts of metal sub genres we'll
have music from all
over the world from big stars to indie
darlings
it's the most diverse song library ever
seen
in music learning software rocksmith
plus will still have our proven practice
features
like adaptive difficulty and riff
repeater which let you practice
and learn at your own pace or slow down
and repeat
tricky parts until you master them we've
improved those features in rocksmith
plus
and are introducing new ones beginner
and intermediate players will benefit
from more
personalized learning thanks to an
enhanced recommendation system
and more robust progress tracking
players won't just see their growth on a
single song
they can now monitor their progress
technique by technique
across the board and overall offer a
better sense of how you're improving
over time advanced players will be happy
to know we're introducing
a new rocksmith tablet review that way
you could take advantage of rocksmith
plus
song library and practice tools in a
format that's familiar
and one that will hone your tab rating
skills we're excited to announce that
you can register for a chance
to participate in our closed beta right
after the show
visit our website at rocksmith.com to
get an early look at rocksmith plus
and help us test and create the future
of music learning
thank you so much to the amazing fans
who have enjoyed
and supported rocksmith over the past 10
years
let's jam together with rocksmith plus
for another 10.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
register now for a chance to play the
rocksmith plus beta
summer is coming and nothing gets thrill
seekers blood flowing like bright sun
and fresh trails
in writer's republic we'll give them
just that last year
you got a first look at our massive
multiplayer outdoor sports extravaganza
since then the project's grown by jumps
and grinds
greetings thrill seekers this is the
rider's ridge
the republic's stomping ground
from here you can meet like-minded
writers
manage your career
learn to nail those wild moves
stay stylish
share your creations with the republic
stay on top of the latest news
[Music]
and take up some ferocious multiplayer
action like free-for-all or trixx battle
our 6th versus 16 competition
so here's how it works performing big
tricks on the modules will turn them
from red to blue and every trick that
you stop
will contribute to your team's overall
score still with me
okay when your team has turned all the
modules blue
you capture that district which will
help multiply your score into the big
time
progress progress progress to unlock
more content you gotta burn those stars
so if you want to be the boss of your
own career
the world's most famous competitions are
waiting for you
now some might say the best parts of the
republic can be found in the city
playground
we've got modules that you can slay for
days
[Music]
maybe you're all about living on the
edge
either way to progress you've got to
earn those stars
having the right rig is important too
we've all got our preferences
all right i get it sometimes you just
want to explore
and bathe in nature
[Music]
that's right everything you do counts
getting those stars means more
rad to be had and the republic will
abide
there's always something awesome to do
as you reach new milestones and unlock
more challenges it's the red bull
joyride people
it's infamous it's spectacular it's the
biggest stage of slope style mountain
biking
and guess what you can play it versus
your friends
[Applause]
there is so so much more
more stunts
more sports more events
just more okay and the natural
outdoor playground for you and your
friends to enjoy
any way that you want
[Music]
when we say fun with everyone we mean it
look at all these riders
[Applause]
does this speak to you then don't miss
out on mass races
the republic awaits you ryder see you
soon
[Music]
don't keep the mountains waiting writers
republic is coming september 2nd and you
can pre-order now
and claim your right to rip
okay so we've seen some of our favorite
rainbow six operators battling alien
parasites but how's their day job going
you know ever since crimson heist we're
still trying to clear all those pesky
flora's drones off the maps
year six is off to a blazing start with
siege passing 200 000 concurrent players
a few weeks ago
if you haven't joined in yet 2021 is the
perfect time to drop
in
[Music]
six years into our journey with siege we
are humble and grateful for the
enthusiastic community
that has supported this growth so today
is all about
sharing quality of life development that
will dramatically improve player
experience
with the community growing every day
we've been hard at work finding ways
to improve your ability to play with
your friends and meet new players
on june 30th we are unifying our pc and
cloud-based platforms with cross-play
and cross-progression
that means that any player on amazon
luna stegia or pc
will be able to queue into games
together while having a unified account
progression
and for console players in early 2022
cosplay will be available between
playstation
and xbox platform and the cross
progression will be available between
all platforms
for these updates we needed a bit more
time in order to prepare and make sure
they have a smooth launch
bringing these player bases together
benefits everyone
it will finally allow you to play with
your friends across different platforms
it also means that your progression will
now follow you
anytime and anywhere you play we know
cosplay
is a feature a lot of you has been
anticipating and we are thrilled to see
the enthusiasm it's announcements
inspired
from your amazing fan art to the awesome
cosplays
the rainbow six community is the
lifeblood that keeps this game moving
forward
we cannot thank you enough for your
support it is because of you
that siege keeps evolving and growing to
wrap up
here's a brand new animated trailer
starring thunderbird
the new defender joining team rainbow
check this out
ready six years ago i met a pilot
she saved my life
there
that symbol what does it mean
this jacket was my father's
the creator's star has many meanings
love wisdom bravery
listen i need to get this bird in the
air you try to get some rest
yo de bus
what's happening
[Music]
uh
that's it what happened next
why don't you ask yourself
new projects aren't the only things to
be excited about this year
take a look at the incredible updates
coming to our live games in 2021
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
like
[Music]
supposed
from the release of the ghost experience
to the latest teammate update
ghost recon breakpoint keeps evolving
thanks to your feedback
but that's not all as 2021 marks the
20th anniversary of the ghost recon
franchise
we are happy to announce that there are
still many more surprises to come
stay tuned ghosts
[Music]
just dance has always been about
connecting with friends and family
when you're in good company there are no
bad dancers so move the coffee table
alert the local homeowners association
and let's get loud
if you wanna get down
hello my name is todder call and i'm a
singer dancer actor
director and choreographer i am super
excited to announce that my song
nell's hair hips hills is going to be a
part of just dance 2022.
[Music]
you me you wish
but that's not all oh no for the first
time ever the just dance team and i are
collaborating to give you
an exclusive version of my song for just
dance 2022.
girl i don't dance i work i don't play i
slay
i don't walk i strut stretch
to me just dance allows people to
express themselves through dance
and to celebrate who they are and their
individuality in such a fun way just
dance has transformed millions of lives
and i hope that this song
brings you all so much joy whether
you're dancing alone or with the group
to work out or just to have fun it's
going to be a great time and i can
assure you you will not just play
you will absolutely slay the new lyrics
were handcrafted specifically for just
dance and let me tell you something
they're full of sass because you know
they were written by yours truly but i
guarantee they are going to give people
so much confidence that's the reason why
i wrote nails hair hips heels and now
it's been just dancified i don't think
they're ready for this jelly i hope you
all have just as much fun dancing to
this track
as i had making it oh and one last thing
you will have the opportunity to be a
part of the making of my new video
which will be released alongside the new
just dance track for more information on
how to participate darling
just check the link below we got you i
cannot wait to see you all
living your best life and being the most
fabulous you have ever been
i will see you all in just dance 2022
girl
i don't dance i work
[Music]
[Music]
y'all know what time it is come on
everybody on the floor
i want to see you work come on
that's all it's time
to get our viking on it was a big year
for the new chief of the raven clan
but your journey with avor is far from
[Music]
over
in november 2020 we released assassin's
creed valhalla
to our delight it was the biggest launch
for any assassin's creed game today
and we have you to thank for that
becoming avor
a viking leader going on a quest to
fight for a new home
is an adventure that resonated closely
with many of you
i certainly had fun exploring england
with avor
and stumbling across unique world events
that left me with memorable side stories
thank you avor we're amazed to see how
you dedicated yourselves to the viking
lifestyle
you've led more than 300 million raids
in total
and built more than a hundred million
buildings in your settlements
congrats a4 still has a long
journey ahead and we've been continuing
to offer free updates for all players to
enjoy
post launch these updates include time
limited festivals
new quests and even whole new game modes
such as the river raids update
and the mastery challenge
we add in community requested tweaks and
features too
for instance we'll be adding one-handed
swords in the coming weeks
the team is also working hard at
tackling issues and improving the game
experience for everyone
we've been tracking various known issues
on our forums and also shared our
complex
bug fixing process in a recent debt blog
we love seeing your continual feedback
and we thank you for your patience and
support for the game
on top of regular free updates we're
also building on avoir's story and the
world of assassin's creed valhalla
through game expansions wrath of the
druids released a few weeks ago
allowing players to explore ireland and
battle a mysterious cult
the children of danu
in our second upcoming expansion you'll
get to relive the siege of paris
this is the most ambitious battle in
viking history
taking place in war-torn frankia you'll
have to do everything in your power to
uncover enemy secrets
and form strategic alliances in order to
safeguard
your clan's future players may be
excited to learn
that black box infiltration missions are
returning
this means you're given a goal for a
mission but how you'll achieve it
is up to you expect new abilities
weapons gear and of course
new enemies watcho for the siege of
paris coming this summer
assassin's creed has long focused on the
exploration of history
and we are happy to announce that the
new discovery tour will be released
this fall it will be free to all who own
assassin's creed valhalla
explore the world and take a deeper dive
into the history of the viking age
the team has crafted a new experience
where you'll get to play as people
during the time of vikings
and follow them in their endeavors big
and small
while collecting exclusive rewards
whether you're an assassin's creed fan
with a heart for history
or a student looking to supplement your
knowledge the discovery tour viking age
will have you covered
assassin's creed valhalla doesn't stop
here
for the first time on an assassin's
creed title we'll be supporting the game
well into its second year while this
year will be a very active year for the
game
we're already working on more expansions
for next year
something tells me that avor is not done
with odin yet
so you've seen some great games from us
but we also have news about the movies
and tv series we've been working on
our ubisoft film and television team has
some exclusive content to share
up first is mythic quest the workplace
comedy set in a game development studio
the streaming on apple tv plus
if you haven't watched the second season
yet here's a look at what you've been
missing before the upcoming season
finale
why do you have goosebumps this is an
involuntary reaction to being inspired i
was emotionally manipulated
what's the difference
that's it that's it that's it except
make it about me and not the world
i feel really seen and hurt i don't want
to see you
or hear you she played us to get what
she wanted
she inspired us she emotionally
manipulated us what's the difference
up next is an exclusive look at a new
trailer for our feature-length movie
werewolves within it's a whodunit with
teeth that'll be coming to theaters
june 25th and on demand july 2nd
hello everyone i am josh rubin the
director of werewolves within
and i'm sam richardson the star of
werewolves within
worlds of them was based off the ubisoft
game and we're so excited to bring you
an exclusive look
just for you check it out
dr ellis
i told you she's probably tanked
touch this door again i'll shoot again
dr
ellis please
we need answers it didn't disappear
what it's not emerson flint
it's one of you
okay what what did her eyeball say we
don't understand
could just please come out i'm afraid i
can't do that ranger wheeler you could
be one of them
one of what
i like
a what a werewolf
[Music]
the roads are something's wrong with the
generator
also there's a dead body under your
porch yes
i'm gonna go get a croissant
out of curiosity who is packing
we having a good old-fashioned sleepover
we're guns with guns yes
everybody's going how the heck
not uh littering i'm just excited not
judging just watching it
[Music]
follow mythic quest on apple tv plus and
be sure to catch werewolves within this
summer
in theaters are on your on demand
platforms
no hero story is complete without a
great rival to match them
after all even the most vile tyrant is
the star of their own narrative
when it comes to memorable villains no
one does it better than far cry
[Music]
please we have to get on that phone
abuela
what the hell i'm gonna do with baseball
cards do you have any idea what these
are worth
let us do marco
always making new friends danny you're
late
where's alejo he gave up his ticket for
his family
[ __ ]
alejo's not going anywhere anymore
come on let them on
[Music]
good man
the bottom
don't worry about it yamako here that's
all i've got
this isn't right danny we should be
fighting not running to the young keys
alego gave you a [ __ ] gift leader we
survive
same as the orphanage same as the
[Music]
academy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we would go out on a boat just like this
and we would catch this
and we would catch the fish and then
release them he would say it's not
always about your
stomach me oh it's about
the challenge except
when he caught a big fat juicy marlin
he was too proud to let that fish go
no you have voices
i have caught a very big fish today
have a night diego
diego
no way
i have caught you mijo now it's time to
bring you home
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go they can work make viviro
truth
or lies truth
they could be good workers
they could help rebuild paradise
but if you wanted them to live
you would have never set foot on this
[ __ ] boat
13 years old diego has
such compassion for his people
these fish
we will catch a release
you've just seen another disturbing
lesson from anton castillo
passed down to his san diego as he
grooms him to become the future
ruler of yara the most important part of
crafting a far cry villain
isn't the fact that they're evil or
shocking
it's that there's someone that could sit
across from you at the dinner table
and charm you into thinking that
everything they believe
no matter how twisted or horrifying
could be absolutely true that's the
secret to anton's power
and we couldn't be prouder to have him
join the fight cry family
now when creating anton we had quite a
lot to live up to
because when you think far cry you think
about its rich legacy of villains
which makes today a very special day for
far cry fans
not only did we get to see into the mind
of anton castillo
we finally get to unveil some of our
post launch plans
our dream was to honor the far cry
villains tradition
and introduce a brand new experience
it is time to see the other side go
further down the rabbit hole
and it's up to you to find a way out
[Music]
what is going on
tell your mother and sister to
you are alive
that is all that matters
peek-a-boo [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i
[Music]
i too am a king who isn't afraid to
slaughter to get what he wants
[Music]
is this a test a dream
an opportunity then i will not waste
you are beyond salvation
did i ever tell you the definition of
insanity
we're so excited for you all to check
out this next game
oh neelam i can't wait to get my hands
on this one
we are now hmm our destination
[Music]
oh
[Music]
vast energy anomaly detected
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the whole team is super proud of this
new game
and i can't wait for you to experience
it
it's fair to say that we did something
quite surprising with the concept of
mario plus rabbit's kingdom battle
and for this project we didn't want to
stop there
hi everyone mario and rebecc
and i'm so excited to be back as well
today to unveil our new
project mario plus rabbit's spark survey
we are diving back into this unique
crossover with
even bigger ambition expanding our
universe
on a major scale this time it's not just
the mushroom kingdom
there is an entire galaxy to save to do
so
you will lead a brave yet reckless team
of unique eels including some fresh
faces
like rabbits rosalina and other
surprises
on their quest to repel evil across the
galaxy
their spaceship will bring them from
planet to planet
they will be facing a powerful villain
cursor an enemy unlike anything
our heroes encountered before
but they won't be alone by their side
they will left their new allies the
sparks
these surprising creatures born from the
merge
of rabbits and lumas will lend
their wild powers to our ears
their natures and origin are at the core
of our story
but let's keep some surprises for later
[Music]
after the tremendous success of mario
plus rabbit's kingdom battle
the entire team was moved by the amazing
reception from players across the world
we were stunned by the love we felt for
this unexpected team-up
we know we've been off the radar for a
while now as we wanted to take the time
needed
to bring this cross over to the next
level
it's not just a new story with new
enemies new heroes
mario plus rabbit sparks of hope has big
ambitions
it introduces new action elements into
the mix that will push the boundaries of
tactical games
even further that being said we also
wish to offer
an easy to play experience for all
players yet hard to master for those of
you that are willing
to take the challenge and you will be
able to experience this cosmic adventure
exclusively on the nintendo switch
we can't wait to tell you more about the
game soon
there is an entire galaxy to save and we
cannot wait
for you to experience it
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
come on
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're not done yet let's check in
with our ceo
eve guimo
everyone as you have seen we have a
fantastic
and diverse lineup of games coming soon
and this is just
the beginning thanks to all the teams at
ubisoft
for what they achieved and for always
striving
to deliver the best possible game
experiences
i'm humbled by their resilience energy
and collaboration
especially during what has been a
challenging year
i'm also proud of our industry's ability
to bring together
millions of players from around the
world
to share memorable experiences and
moments of joy
this is one of the real powers
of video games and it is what motivates
everyone at ubisoft to do our best
finally my sincere thanks to you
the players we appreciate the trust
you place in us your involvement in our
games communities
keep them growing and vibrant
we want to create original enriching
long-lasting game words
and your contributions feedback and
support
make it possible we also are proud
that some of the biggest names in
entertainment
trust our creative teams to develop
games
within their universes for example
you just saw mario plus rabbit sparks of
hope
developed in collaboration with nintendo
where everyone's favorite
mario and rabbids characters return for
an
all-new adventure
[Music]
and speaking of great partnerships there
is one more
exciting thing we would like to show you
today
it is a glimpse of the amazing journey
that awaits you in one of the most
beautiful
but dangerous places of all brought to
life by the latest version of our
snowdrop engine
i'm excited to share this first look
with you now
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you understand now
you and i are gonna test
it out
that is crazy
[Music]
awesome
too much fun
[Music]
thanks to eve and all the devs that
joined us to share what's new with
ubisoft
today we battled some archaeans in
rainbow six extraction
learned some new songs in rocksmith got
an adrenaline rush from writer's
republic
lit up the dance floor in just dance
2022 visited new shores and assassin's
creed valhalla
witness the chilling confrontation in
far cry 6 and teamed up with our
favorite man in overalls in mario plus
rabbits
don't go anywhere there's still more to
come in the post show
bye y'all
[Music]
i think it's important to have a first
nations character in a mainstream game
because indigenous women especially
are very underrepresented in mainstream
media
and that's what we're hoping to to
change with this character
the creation of thunderbird does have
immense potential to
bust on all those all those negative
stereotypes about even indigenous women
indigenous people
if there's anything that can help target
an audience to
become more interested in nakota
community
it's probably technology and ubisoft is
right in touch with the highest
technology
games and and something like this can
have a really
big impact on youth and
i'm excited to see the outcome of of
thunderbird
thunderbird was born in the nakota
territories in saskatchewan
her civilian name is mina skye she
values her community
and she's also a protector whether it's
of
people the community or the land
we knew that we wanted this character to
be
a pilot a helicopter pilot but we didn't
know exactly in which field she would be
working
so i asked the consultants if they had
any sort of feedback or information that
they wanted to take into consideration
when picking the work
field in which this character would be
working i suggested that thunderbird
be a technical expert within hydrology
because
we believe as nakota people that water
is life
and that within that is the struggle of
protecting and
preserving the environment when we
started talking about weapons or tools
that this character would have
we were kind of tossing around different
names i made a suggestion
and say nakota words as as simply as
possible
that kona would be actually a good name
because it means friend
thunderbirds gadget is a little bit
unique
she is going to be our second operator
who can
raise the help of their teammates
however
it can also heal your opponents so
kona quite literally is a friend to
everyone
long ago especially the northern dakota
tribes of the great plains
we tattooed our faces and that's
something that has been forgotten
even in our own histories now it's
something that we're starting to talk
about
something that we want to bring back
that's what i wanted to see with this
character was
to grab someone's interest enough to
want to go
out there and find and do research of
their own of who the nakoda are
what are the dakota am i a nakota what's
my language what's my culture what does
this symbol mean
thunderbird would not have existed
without the input of
torina jessica and shayna they honestly
created this character from the ground
up
we never really knew each other and we
were so excited to talk about this
character
and we talked about water we talked
about her name and
we talked about all of these things that
you know that's going to represent
a strong woman warrior she's going to be
representing she's going to be carrying
and you know that was that was really
what was cool about working with
with ubisoft and this character
considered
she's really bringing such an ancient
historic people
into the present i hope that honors her
and all
indigenous women and all indigenous
people
i feel that us consultants worked very
carefully
and respectfully to develop a character
that would make nakota
people proud this is something that's
going to
really impact with kids that aren't a
coda
i might just you know purchase a a game
console and try it out myself
[Music]
hey everyone thanks for joining us we've
got a great show lined up for you today
we've got a bunch of amazing folks from
dev team members
members of the community and our
community team who are going to take you
through a bunch of great topics
related to the upcoming season of siege
coming hot on the heels of that making
of video of thunderbird
we'd like to take you behind the scenes
of her design
in order to help you with that we have
alex karposis
from the dev team thanks for joining us
today absolutely
pleasure to be here so before we dive
into thunderbird specifically
i'd love to hear about the process of
making an operator
what goes into this and what steps are
involved in deciding
what to base a character around starting
an operator
starts with a lot of exploration on the
gameplay side there's a bunch of gadgets
we want to try out
things that are interesting for
abilities
on a universe side there's interesting
bios that we want to explore
different kind of people we want to
introduce to the cast of characters of
siege
and on the character concept side
uh we want to play with different forms
and silhouettes
something that you haven't really seen
before in siege
in terms of thunderbird as a character
where did that conception begin
thunderbird was really interesting
the entire team knew that we wanted to
feature somebody from the first nations
in north america
this is our backyard we wanted to
represent somebody
from that huge community but we didn't
know where to start
and we eventually found that it all
really started from the casting
we wanted to find somebody who could
speak their native language
bring an incredible performance to the
character and
really do justice to who the character
we want to build is
so this all began with our star who is
sarah lee's
mcarthur uh and she really was the
driving force
behind thunderbird she knows how to
speak nakoten
she has an incredible voice and that's
really what honed in on the idea of a
nakoden
operator in rainbow six siege in
addition to working closely on the
casting side of things
i also understand that you worked really
closely as we saw in the making of video
with consultants um i know you've
mentioned
that the symbolism was a really
important part of where
the consultants came into play was there
anything in particular with the
iconography that they helped with
the consultants were immensely helpful
and so supportive of what we were trying
to do with thunderbird
once we knew that we wanted to feature a
nakoden
operator that's when we found three
amazing consultants
one of them being an artist to start
working on the background of the
operator and the visuals
and so when you take a look at
thunderbird there's actually a lot
of emblems and iconography that has a
lot
of emotion and meaning behind them
are there any that you'd be able to dig
into specifically right now
every single badge on thunderbird has a
meaning
uh if you take a look at the back of her
jacket for instance
the six-pointed star which is a huge
huge
symbol for the nakota nation it
represents so many things
uh most of all balance balance between
uh life and death between masculine and
feminine
that was a really important thing we
needed to nail and we worked really
closely
with the consultants to make sure that
that emblem was meaningful
and respectful of everything we wanted
to represent thunderbird
that's amazing um and i feel like one of
the other things
that's really really identifiable on
thunderbird's jacket
is the word wagiyah uh what does that
mean to thunderbird
so wagiya is thunderbird and nakoden
and also we wanted to make sure that
that
language was visible on the character
just like it's something that you can
hear
thunderbird speak in the animated short
that we released
making sure that the language was a part
of the character
was very important and that's why you
see it on the back of the jacket too
so working with sarah elise macarthur on
the animated trailer were there any big
takeaways
on your side i think uh the biggest
takeaway
was we learned so much from our
consultants from sarah's macarthur
and the hope is too that many many more
people
can learn about the nakota people
their language their art and
really open up opportunities for people
to investigate
and learn more about these amazing
people
thanks for taking the time to bring us
through the design of thunderbird
in the meantime we're going to jump into
the animated trailer that we mentioned
before
but if there's anyone you'd like to
thank alex uh you have the floor
i just want to thank the team for being
so incredible thunderbird was an immense
amount of work
and i know everybody's so extremely
proud of her
and i also know that they're already
hard at work on the next couple of
operators that are already being worked
on so
thank you so much it means a lot to so
many people to share these operators
with the world
ready six years ago i met a pilot
she saved my life
that symbol what does it mean
this jacket was my father's dagu
the creator's star has many meanings
love wisdom bravery
listen i need to get this bird in the
air you try to get some rest
yo bus
what's happening
[Music]
huh
wait that's it what happened next
why don't you ask yourself
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone my name is josh i'm one of
the crs for rainbow six siege and you
may also know me as ub yellow on the
ubisoft forums
steam and reddit with the release of
north star we figured this would be a
good opportunity to discuss
some of the top issues that we have gone
over over the past year
without further ado let's dive right
into it up first
let's talk about smoke propagation and
smoke's toxic babes
we're excited to announce that with the
release of north star
smoke's toxic canisters will no longer
clip through ceilings
floors or walls
up next bullet hole peaking we know that
for players it can be frustrating to get
killed through a bullet hole
and not necessarily know where that
bullet hole came from with north star
we're excited to announce that bullet
holes in soft surfaces will no longer
leave
small holes that will give an unfair
advantage to peakers
players need to fire multiple bullets to
create larger rotations
and it's worth mentioning that thin
materials like window glass barricades
and the inner core of props will not be
affected by this change
next let's dive into some of the
gameplay focus issues that are affecting
our community
we are improving the way the game
detects flashes so that you can be more
confident knowing how it will affect
your opponent
to solve this we are simulating the way
light bounces off objects in the
environment and evaluating the strengths
of flashes to make sure that they are
balanced
we're happy with the results so far and
are now testing it to make sure it meets
the standards in the heat of a match
and we are currently aiming for a year 6
season 3 launch for this
up next let's talk about certain skins
that are difficult to see
we know that when you're peeking down a
corridor you want to make sure that
you're actually seeing your opponent
where they are
and we know that there are certain skins
that make this a little bit difficult
for our players
to combat this we are introducing rim
lighting
that way all cosmetics have a similar
visibility across the board
we are currently aiming for a year 6
season 3 release for this
so be sure to stay tuned to our social
media for updates
next we'd like to talk about some issues
that tie into your wider player
experience with siege
when it comes to cheating and toxicity
we know these topics are important for
our community
just as much as they are for us in our
last anti-cheat dev vlog
we mentioned that we are working on
building new cheat detections
based on statistics to uncover our most
disruptive cheat users
while this process was originally manual
to stress tests and help
validate its accuracy we are excited to
announce that this process
is now automatic this means that
sanctions for cheaters identified
through data based means will come
quicker
and reduce their impact on our community
implementing an automatic process
also allows us to work in parallel and
strengthen our collaboration
with battle eye we are also taking the
time to further evolve the mmr rollback
system
by improving its reactivity and
minimizing its negative impact on our
players
the goal of mmr rollback was to help
players when they are in an unfair match
that being said we know that when you
win against a team
it can be very frustrating so we are
working to address that
as we work towards a clear and fair
system we are not able to share an exact
timeline at this moment
but we are working towards and aiming
for a season three release for this
so be sure to look out for more updates
we have also
increased sanction penalties for
abandon-related offenses
and this will be for ranked and unranked
and you will see this at the beginning
of northstar
paired with the recent improvements to
the mass cancellation
we expect this to help discourage this
form of griefing while limiting the
impact on our committed players
now this is only just a snapshot of what
we're working on
later on this week we will share a top
issues article that will recap
these and some of our other top related
issues
on top of this we are also hard at work
on focused updates for specific top
issues like an update to our anti-cheat
dev blog so stay tuned for more
all right and now we're here to talk
about something very near and dear to my
heart that's the sixth guardian program
the program launched year five season
four and it was a way for
us to focus the efforts of the siege
community on
a good cause and at the time that first
uh
that first crack at it was with our
friends over ablegamers
throughout the course of that season we
were able to raise over 170
000 us dollars for ablegamers charity uh
so it was a great success we thank
everybody who contributed
bought the cool skin that we made with
them all the proceeds from those
purchases go to the charity by the way
and uh we're not stopping the program
there in fact
we're here today to reveal our next
iteration on the program
starting in year six season two north
star and we are joined by a
representative and in fact the ceo
of our next charity right here his name
is steve
machuga from stack up steve how are you
doing
i'm doing good eric thanks for having me
on my pleasure
um we go back a long way we're always
been looking for cool ways to work
together and uh
i think this is probably the coolest one
we've found pretty damn cool thanks
what is stack up why why don't you walk
us through what your organization does
so stack up is a military charity we
provide support to us and allied
veterans through our four main programs
we have our supply crate program where
we send xboxes and playstations to
units deployed forward we have our air
assault program where we fly disabled
they're deserving veterans to various
gaming events like comic-con e3 packs
or to studio tours to check out their
favorite games this uh how they get made
our stacks program where we have little
fire teams of volunteers that get out
and do good things in their neighborhood
volunteer where they can
and then finally last but not least we
have our overwatch program which is our
24 7
suicide prevention team for veterans
online through our discord channel
if you're having a tough time you need
someone to talk to our volunteers are
there and ready to
ready to go and uh if it's okay to say
you yourself served overseas didn't you
uh eight years in the army uh four years
infantry four years intel
and is that sort of what gave you a bit
of inspiration on
the downtime yeah yeah
gaming was uh definitely something that
i used both overseas and when i came
back home to
reacclimatize myself to being back home
it's a definitely a strange
reality uh stepping off the plane and
just going down the street to get a
chili dog it's like
where did i just come from again oh my
what in the world it's a very rough
transition so having something to kind
of
walk me back into reality playing video
games as that and a lot of our
guys and gals use gaming to kind of uh
fill up that that tough time in their
lives where they need a little bit of
help
whether it's staying in touch with other
veterans or people that they're no
longer in contact with they can play
games together across the country from
one another
gaming works out is a wonderful way to
keep veterans motivated
their morale high and generally part of
the conversation
now one thing that was interesting that
you mentioned in there right at the top
is it's not just a us-only charity
you're
serving uh military organizations
outside of the u.s is that right
one of the things that we try to impress
upon people just because we're based in
the united states
we are not just a us-based charity we
help
u.s and allied veterans which means if
you put on a uniform and you're one of
our allies through nato or anzac
australia new zealand uh any of our
allies out there
we will work with you and that fits in
perfectly with the theme of what rainbow
six is
right exactly it's it's it's it's very
strange like i was actually reading the
original rainbow six
book uh while i was uh in ranger school
so it was a very weird reality
of uh you know this multinational
anti-terrorism unit and you know being
it was
so so crazy that here we are now you
know almost 20 years later
and uh yeah it's it's it's amazing how
far we've come as an organization
so how do you feel about partnering with
siege uh and our community on this
oh it's super exciting i mean you guys
over ubisoft sure know how to
run games as a service it's it's amazing
and we're happy to be a part of it
it's a wild ride working on siege and i
don't think any of us would uh would
ever change it so without further ado
we've talked a lot but i'm sure people
want to actually see what this bundle
looks like
so we're going to pull up some images
here of the bundle and we'll reveal that
it's a skin in fact for valkyrie so
let's have a look there
uh steve how do you feel about this
bundle a big fan i was
i was a balcomane for a long time
primarily because of my potato aim
and uh just being able to throw cameras
around and watch
avenues of approach as people trying to
come in uh
i i get the intel over to the guys who
can actually make the shots
so that's that's where i like to playing
uh primarily as a support
support class about the perfect choice
the valk
six guardian stack up bundle will be
available as soon as year 6 season 2
north star launches this week and it's
going to run for the entire
season so you have a whole season's
worth of time
to buy that bundle and the proceeds from
your purchase
go directly to stack up and it's great
cause
so please consider it steve thank you so
much for joining us today
and before i let you go i thought i'd
give you a chance to let the people know
how they can contribute how they can
help out
or get involved with stack up apart from
buying this bundle if you're interested
in learning more about stack up and how
we support veterans and mental health
for veterans uh head on over to
stackup.org
we're on the website our discord
channels discord.gigi
backslash stackup.org head on over there
and some of our volunteers will be right
there with you if you know someone
who could use our help that's a great
place to put in a request form as well
so yeah please head on over and we're
happy to help out wherever we can
hey everyone i'm here with guillaume to
talk about cross play and cross
progression coming to rainbow six siege
some amazing announcements today in our
show and we'd like to spend a little
time talking about these
first let's talk about stadia so how and
when will this rollout happen estelia
we're very excited about it is going to
be out
and released on june 13th for everybody
uh so on june 13th you'll be able to
play onstage
and you will also be able to play with
pc player
and your progression will also follow
you
whenever you play on studio or on pc
that's amazing i know everyone's very
excited about cross progression
and cross play speaking of that
question on people's mind is will pc and
console
have cross play between them no not for
now
we are going to have separate
matchmaking pools and cross play pools
pc will be on a side with cloud-based
platforms and
console in the future will be together
got it
so and to be clear when we talk about
console cosplay
are we which generations are we talking
about we're going to talk about
every generation a ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox
one x
perfect now it's something that is a
highly anticipated community feature so
um let's talk a little bit about the
console cost
crossplay coming what steps do we need
to take now
to make this thing happen uh we're gonna
need to be very careful on how we do it
because as you know
siege is a live game so it's like
changing the wheels
of the of the car while we are riding on
the highway right
so we're going to have a lot of work to
do on the ui to make sure that all the
flow the invite flows
are working properly and we'll also have
a lot of work to do on the
tech side to be sure that all the
different and separate environment that
we have
right now are merged into one so that
they can support cosplay and cross
progression
this is going to be a community question
that pops up with cross playing
uh cross progression does this mean when
console cross play happens that we
will be supporting mouse and keyboard on
consoles so
this is a in indeed a very good question
um we are working
on looking what we're going to do it and
how we're going to handle it
um that's for sure that's it's something
that is on our world map
but it's a very complicated topic and
again
uh the idea is to make sure that we do
it properly so
uh yes input input spoofing uh
and how we manage them in the
matchmaking is uh on our top priority
list yes for that feature
yeah that makes sense so if console
cross play is coming in 2022
what can we expect between now and then
uh first step will be
uh the release of the stadia version in
june 30th
and after that we're going to be out at
work making sure that everything is
ready for the console lunch early next
year
amazing well i think that's awesome i
think i speak for everyone we always say
we're very excited for this to happen
uh in the meantime everyone keep an eye
out on channels throughout the year and
we'll keep you updated on the progress
as we bring crossplay to rainbow six
siege
thank you
hey everyone rainbow six siege is an
extremely dedicated and talented
creative community
and we've been working on quite some
time and finding ways how to get the
science created by our fan artists into
the game
in march 2021 we launched a community
artist bundle program together with
prime gaming
and the very first community created
bundle by saw siege
for the operator cavera the response of
the community has been absolutely
fantastic so big shout out to saw siege
for creating this fabulous set
today we're extremely excited to
announce the year 6 season 2 fan artist
bundle
designed by the one and only sun stark
sunstark has been a pillar in our
community with her amazing fan art for
siege
and she has a very unique story to share
because while we were creating her
bundle
she was actually hired by ubisoft to
work on siege full-time
she's here on the show with us today so
welcome sun stark
and why don't you tell us a little bit
more about yourself and your story
hi i'm sunshine kim you know me more as
sun stark i'm a character concept artist
working
in the video game industry since 2015
i started drawing rainbow sixties fan
art
since velvet shell season night i'm a
big fan of military shooting games
so the general aesthetics of this game
character designs and character lore and
they
those old things really appealed to me
at the time so
for me it was a good stress relief to
draw c's fan art after a long day at
work
and here i am in 2021 i
officially work for rainbow sixties now
so you were a fan artist and reached out
to you about creating
your bundle and can you tell us how your
journey was from
being a fan artist to actually being an
employee and working on siege
let's say that it was like double
lottery wins
uh it was already a big honor for me to
be invited to this amazing program that
to be immortalized
in the game and during the production
bring
during the production of this bundle i
actually got approached by the the uh
the art team of rainbow six seas that if
i'm
if i would be interested in applying for
the
role on the team so i did i applied
uh and i got hired
it all happened in two months and it was
crazy yeah
absolutely incredible so what is your
position within siege exactly
i'm a character concept artist working
on rainbow six c's team
so that includes a battle pass skins or
like elite skins or new
operators now let's have a very first
look at the bundle you've created
so you chose to create this bundle for
lion
why did you choose this character in
particular
yes lion is indeed my favorite operator
um if you follow my social medias
90 of my contents include lions so
it's not a secret i
i just found the character really uh
the lore is really interesting to me uh
it's quite dramatic it's not for
everybody
but he's just unique personality
not good but unique his unique
personality
uh
causing trouble with other operators
and he's really really dark past
and his relationship with his son and
everything
it just made the character super rich
and
i enjoyed adding my interpretation to
every fan art i did for him what
inspired you
to create this bundle there's one time
that i did
a fan skin for lion which was
firefighter theme
and uh to be honest i went in
super lightheartedly i just enjoyed
aesthetic i just enjoyed
mashing up firefighter uniform and then
all the tactical gears together
it was just fun creative process
when i posted it up i got several
several messages from actual
firefighters in our community
and they were all thanking me all i did
was just
drawing a fan art of my favorite
character but they were thanking me for
representing them
in my art so when ubisoft approached to
me
and presented this idea of course i'm
going to take it
i immediately thought i gotta make that
fan skin to be real so yeah there was no
other option it was going to be
firefighters since the beginning
and yeah this is my tribute to first
responders in our community
you had that idea in your mind of
creating a firefighter skin for lion
and now we'll have it soon in the game
can you tell us a little bit about that
process
from getting the idea in your head into
the game
yeah absolutely i i really enjoyed
working with the seas team
and remember this was before i joined
the team so i was just a
fan artist i was just a fan they treated
me like i was
on site artist so it was a really good
it was it was a good taste for me to
what it's like to work with the system
and the 3d artist that i
worked with was just amazing amazing
uh amazingly talented artist that i'm
really happy with the outcome i'm glad
that i got to taste that
process before i joined the team thank
you so much for being here on the show
with us today
telling us more about yourself and your
bundle
and we're incredibly excited until the
release we can't wait to see it in game
thank you for having me here i can't
wait to see
bundle either and i can't wait for you
to finally see my son
we're sure you all want to know how you
can get your hands on the lion bundle
and when so the bundle will be available
shortly after the release
of your 6 season 2 next week and it will
be available via prime gaming
which means it will be free for all
prime members so make sure that your
amazon ubisoft accounts are linked
and keep an eye out on our social
channels and our website for any more
information about this
you